joining me now for reaction in New York
is monica crowley who is a senior fellow
at the London Center for Policy Research
and also in New York is Julie Alvin
she's a digital director of lifestyle
titles at Time Inc all right Julie I
said a lot in that angle so tell me what
I got wrong correct me tutor me Julie go
ahead frankly I think it's almost
bizarre that you believe that this is
some sort of liberal conspiracy
constructed to you know collect email
addresses to campaign for 2018 these
women are standing up not just for
people in their industry but they're
standing up specifically in this letter
for women who are unable to speak up for
themselves women who are in low-paying
jobs who are farm workers who are
working at hospitals who are working in
hospitality or working in hotels at
restaurants women who do not have the
funds don't have the platform to talk
about sexual harassment but who do
experience large amounts of sexual
harassment they're connecting these
women with legal experts they're
connecting them with with money they're
they're laboring and lobbying
organizations for legislation that you
know helps people speak out against this
that penalizes places that use
non-disclosure agreements to silence
women who have been victims of sexual
abuse so I'm I'm I'm honestly confused
on why you seem this nefarious project I
think that it's not a national woman
with law Center that very long title
that's kind of you know at the core of
this effort
it was just started in October and one
of the core mission statements of this
group is focused on Donald Trump you
don't think that lends some political
taint to the otherwise you know laudable
goal of protecting women and the
workforce this from an industry that has
made millions and millions of dollars
hyper-sexualized in women taking
advantage of young women who are naive
and frankly ignorant of the way men
could be and are oftentimes in the
workplace now suddenly they get millions
of dollars for an organization that's
populated by all liberal actresses as
far as I can tell and we're supposed to
believe oh they've just found their
conscience on this I mean it doesn't
even pass a straight face test mantas
are it's totally it's totally logical
that that's what this group would be
about when they focused on Trump right
in the beginning I think that this is
you know the things that you point out
about this industry hyper-sexualized
women and treating women poorly and
putting images of women out there that
sort of unsavory I think that's exactly
what part of this initiative is trying
to address so you know 80 some percent
of board members in Hollywood are mad 96
percent of Directors are men 71 percent
of writers in Hollywood are men and when
these stories that do objectify women
are largely being told by men I think
part of what this initiative is doing
especially with the part of the
initiative that's trying to define
gender parity these stories aren't just
being tailed by men women like their own
stories women write their own stories
about how what knows what they're going
to do the directors are men so I would
say that all right let's go to Monica I
got to get to Monica Monica look when
they have a group called 50/50 for
gender parity by 2020 2020 is a
presidential election year I don't think
it takes it you know a you know genius
to figure out that there might be more
than just a philanthropic goal here
behind this effort your thoughts yeah
Laura this looks like the latest
mobilization of Saul Alinsky's phrase
never let a good crisis go to waste
the sexual harassment crisis is real
women do suffer at the hands of
superiors and men across every industry
as we have seen but what we have just
seen here in the last couple of weeks
and certainly with these latest two
groups is an effort by the left to take
this genuine crisis and hijack it into
two directions one in this liberal
left-wing
direction and more specifically to have
women that now supplant men in in
positions of power and authority if
women genuinely deserve those positions
more power to them but if they don't if
this is just going to amount to yet
another quota system then we have a
problem the other direction that this is
being mobilized in Laura is the
direction of Donald Trump in many ways
the accusers of Donald Trump in in
late October of last year right before
the election that in a way was ahead of
its time right before the Harvey
Weinstein story broke all of this wide
open what they want to do is make those
accusers relevant again they're going to
try to reanimate this whole thing in
order to target Donald Trump you guys
are the only ones trying to politicize
guys we got to get into another issue
and I want to explore something else
with you and show you how this type of
thing can manifest itself that big
dollars being raised big bucks being
dedicated to derail the Trump presidency
is what I'm saying about with this
charge of sexual misconduct this
happened shortly before the election on
New Year's Eve the New York Times
reported that Hillary Clinton backers
David Brock and Susie Tompkins Bell gave
$700,000 to Lisa blooms law firm now
that money was to support any woman who
would come forward with allegations
against candidate Trump but not one
woman took the offer what does that tell
you Julie is there any political taint
with that money coming from Hillary's
good friend David Brock I understand
where you're coming from in this I
certainly don't like the idea of
exploiting or specifically going after
digging up that sort of dirt in order to
you know for political means that said
it's not like this money was supposed to
go directly towards those people who
potentially may be acting and making
accusations this was money to go towards
relocation expenses towards legal fees
towards concrete things like that and
you know again I don't like the idea of
sort of trying to dig and potentially
exploit people who have legitimately
been sexually harassed or abused but
there is evidence that you know there
have been lots of allegations against
Donald Trump for sexual harassment he's
spoken openly himself about touching
women in a sexual manner without their
consent and so there's concern there
there's smoke and I think that you know
there are women out there who have been
mistreated by Donald Trump and I think
that our country deserves to know about
that so David Brock is a longtime pal of
Hillary's runs all these you know you
know groups that support Hillary Clinton
and others he was at one time a
conservative you wrote a book exposing
Anita Hill now it's pretty ironic is it
mónica that anita hill is is brought in
by hollywood to you know to oversee this
effort to I guess expunge all sexual
bias from Hollywood or at least try to I
agree with you Monica what you said
there are men in positions of power
abuse their positions and take advantage
of young women especially who need an
opportunity there is also a political
element running right through this as
most of the people recently accused most
not all have been people on the left and
that's just a fact and all these
Hollywood people who have been who have
been accused I don't think there's one
is there one conservative I don't maybe
there's one or two people but most of
these people happen to be Democrats
that's another reason I think this
movement has been broadened out leading
up to 2020 you can close it out well in
this story on Brock and and this money
that went into Lisa blooms firm Lisa
bloom the so-called champion of women
and women's rights right we are seeing a
weaponization of sexual harassment which
i think is a genuine tragedy Laura
because there are real cases and the the
real women who have been victimized by
this kind of bad behavior are now going
to have their credibility fall into
greater question whether or not Lisa
bloom or some of these other political
activists are by their side and that's
the real tragedy here